oh sup are you watching harry potter
have you seen it yeah i've seen harry
potter many times what harry potter i
mean yeah the hobbits they
they're like this is not lord of the
rings this is harry do you want to what
do you want to watch
fat hobbit in particular he is not a
hobbit he's a wizard yes why do you keep
calling harry potter lord of the rings
san wise what movie is this are you mad
at me i love frodo i love sanwi's gange
i love that's lord of the rings
i've seen lord of the rings i know the
difference between lord of the rings i
feel like you're mad at me is this
because i forgot the netflix password i
need to be totally honest i don't i
don't know what i'm watching but it's
it's lord of the rings the three hobbits
there's no hobbits yeah if they're not
the hobbits why are they shorter than
all the other characters then because
they're children why do they call them
harry ron i answered this i told you it
was a practical joke that the actors
played on each other but this seems to
be a serious moment why would they play
a joke during seriously they're very
unprofessional god i just want to finish
the show lord of the rings harry potter
these are the show box sets they change
the art what's the title season one
season two what is the title lord of the
rings and what does the other dvd say
harry potter thank you again the graphic
design team was in on the on the
practical joke
the graphic design team
they
they thought the practical joke was
funny they took it to heart and so they
put it on the box that confused a lot of
people sales went down can you just stop
lying to me you clearly haven't seen
lord of the rings all right fine fine i
haven't seen lord of the rings i've been
watching harry potter this whole time
like it's so flipping hard listen we can
watch it together okay
i don't think it'll make anything better
but
fine
so what do you think dumbledore sure can
kick some ass
[Music]